Dann kommen wir jetzt eh gleich mal zu diesen Bullschen ausdrücken.
Den Namen haben wir eben, diesen George Bull, da zu verrankten.
Und Bullians sind praktisch sehr simple Datentypen, die entweder nur 0 oder 1 sein können, also war oder falsch.
Und im Beifen definieren wir die eben als true oder false.
Und das kann eben sowas sein.
Und zwar ist das hier in diesem Fall 2 plus 2 ist 4, ist kleiner als 4.
Und das ist natürlich falsch, weil 4 ist gleich 4.
Das heißt, wir haben diese Vergleichsoperatoren, die uns eben Bullians ermöglichen oder praktisch ausgeben.
Und da gibt es ganz verschiedene Vergleichsoperatoren, da haben wir einmal dieses ist gleich,
dann haben wir das ist nicht gleich, das größer als, das kleiner als,
dann auch kleiner gleich als, größer gleich als.
Und dann haben wir noch 2 spezielle, das ist das ist und das ist nicht.
Das sollte ich vielleicht auch noch kurz erklären.
Ich habe das gestern kurz erwähnt, dass eine Variable,
die ist praktisch eigentlich nur so eine Art Label für eine Adresse irgendwo.
Also die, der Computer sieht die eigentlich eher so, F, A, 0, B.
Einfach ein Hexatezimaladresse und da steht dann der Wert 5 drin, wenn wir da zum Beispiel 5.
Also das hier benennen wir einfach X.
Und jetzt können wir eben, das war auch bei einer der Antworten oder einer der Fragen,
bei dem Feedback gerade davor, was wenn wir jetzt sagen Y ist gleich X.
Dann ist einerseits der Wert gleich, aber Y hat auch die gleiche Adresse hier.
Und das ist eigentlich der große Unterschied für zwischen dem hier und ist,
der hier vergleicht nur die Werte und der vergleicht die Adresse.
Das heißt, wir können daraus finden, ob die Variable auf die selbe Adresse zeigt, wie die andere Variable.
Gibt es dazu Fragen oder ist es, ja, okay.
Das Gleiche geht natürlich auch mit IsNot.
Speziell ist da auch das Nann Keyword.
Und zwar machen wir beim Nann, also wenn wir Nann schauen wollen, ist X, da machen wir immer IsNann.
Und nicht, ist gleich, ist gleich.
Das liegt darin, dass Nann ein bisschen speziell ist.
Das ist ein eigener Datentyp, der immer wirklich eine eigene spezielle Adresse hat und wirklich unfreinderbar ist.
Das ist eben sowas wie eine Konstante.
Genau, und wir bekommen da immer ein True oder False raus, also ein Wow oder Falsch.
Und da gibt es dann in Python verschiedene Operatoren.
Da haben wir zum Beispiel das Ohr, das End und das Not.
Das sind eigentlich eh die wichtigsten.
Das heißt praktisch, ich kann dann hier in meinem If rein, if X ist Nann, direkt Ohr schreiben.
Und dann werden die verodert.
Und wie das praktisch, was der Unterschied zwischen Ohr, End und Not ist, kommen wir gleich.
Wichtig zu wissen ist, dass zuerst ist immer die Verneinung, dann das End und dann das Ohr.
Also von der Ausführung.
So was hab, dann wird zuerst das hier ausgeführt, dann das hier und dann ganz am Schluss noch das Ohr.
Genau, also End haben wir, also wenn wir zwei Sachen verunden, dann ist das Ergebnis nur true, falls beide Sachen wahr sind.
Bei Ohr muss nur eines der beiden Sachen wahr sein und Not ist einfach eine Verneinung praktisch.
Wenn unser Bullenwert wahr war, dann mit Not ist es jetzt falsch.
Und das schaut dann eben so aus, da gibt es eine tolle Wahrheitstabelle.
Das heißt einfach, wir haben hier true, true ergibt bei und true und der Rest eigentlich immer false.
Bei Ohr ergibt praktisch eigentlich nur false, false, false.
Weil wir hier immer einen Wahrheitswert haben und das ist einfach die Regierung.
Gibt es da zu fragen?
Dann noch kurz vielleicht zu den anderen Operatoren, also wir sehen hier eh schon Ohr, End und Not,
aber das sind eigentlich die, die ganz zum Schluss ausgeführt werden.
Also wenn man praktisch, sagen wir mal, wir machen wirklich eine ultra lange, einen Einzeiler, wie man das so schön nennt.
Zum Beispiel machen wir 2 hoch 2, dann multiplizieren wir das mit 2, dann noch plus 2 und so weiter und so fort.
Dann wird praktisch zuerst das hier ausgeführt, dann das hier, dann das hier und so weiter und so fort.
Praktisch ganz unten ist das, was zuerst ausgeführt wird und dann geht es nach oben, was zuletzt ausgeführt wird.
Hier gibt es eben noch so spezielle Operatoren wie ADD, das ist zum Beispiel eine Matriz-Multiplikation,
aber das glaube ich, würde ich in dieser Folie schon ja nicht brauchen.
Genau, Division, Ganzzahldivision und Modulo oder halt Rest.
Plus Minus, dann gibt es noch so Bit-Operatoren, damit kann man Bits verschieben.
Das kann man sich so vorstellen, dass in Wirklichkeit, wenn praktisch alle Daten,
nehmen wir jetzt mal zum Beispiel eine Ganzzahl, einen Integer her,
dann wird der eigentlich intern vom Computer in Benärzahl repräsentiert.
Das heißt, wir haben 1, 2, 4, das heißt, wir haben 1, 0, 1, das ist unsere Benärzahl.
Und mit dieser Schiftooperation, zum Beispiel 2, kann man das Ganze eben nach vorne schiften.
Das heißt, wir haben dann 1, 0, 1, 0, 0 stehen.
Und das ist dann für die ganz schlauen, die machen dann ganz schnelle Berechnungen damit.
Aber ja, das ist auch nicht so etwas, was ihr wahrscheinlich in der Vorlösung hier brauchen wird.
Aber ja, falls man wirklich tiefer in die Materie einsteigen will,
dann muss man sich vertraut sein, dass also mit diesen Bits, mit diesen Benäherzahlen,
praktisch sollte man sich auskennen, aber ja, gibt es dazu Fragen sonst?
Stimmt, ich glaube, Benärzahlen wird sogar gemacht in der Vorlösung,